today on the anime zone or reveal
welcome to the NHK an anime tackling all
the important social issues in Japan
right now such as suicide pacts
addiction to MMORPGs otaku ISM and of
course hentai games and taking hentai
game paintings really hence our games
hentai games brilliant
the slice of flab Jonah and I have had a
strange relationship in the time I've
been watching anime I don't know there
are many slice-of-life animes that I
like but every time I hear about new
interesting one it just takes me about
lifetime in the heart before I can
actually motivate myself to watch it
probably because every time hear the
term slice of life I always seem to
imagine happy-go-lucky it's either get
involved some stupid cheesy love
triangle or generally doing stuff for
Tinian would resemble everyday life in
the same way that marathoning Willa
Twyla movies in one day would resemble
any semblance of fun oh wait
and in the wild world of anime there a
lot of things that sound a lot more
interesting such as people beating the
[ __ ] out of each other epic wine games
girls with very big guns wearing very
little clothing and girls with big guns
wearing wearing their clothing but then
again welcome to the endless care has
been requested up the art but what you
guys and what better way is that to
thank weed guys forgets me over 2000
subscribers sorry such a touch here has
a problem he's 22 years old a college
dropout an easy geeky Komori what this
means is he spends all his time locked
up in his apartment either sleeping
watching TV or smoking his [ __ ] all day
but he is smoking cigarettes so they not
blowing his homosexual male partner for
you Americans out there now I get it
suck me dry Sutter believes he's been
called a huge conspiracy critics by the
Japanese TV station NHK in their evil
plan to turn the entire country into
hiki Kimora's how do they achieve this
epic line you asked by airing addictive
anime
what yes he then confirmed his theory by
conversing with his fridge so you know
right there that somewhere along the
line he took one too many knocks to the
head and went off to cuckoo land but all
hope is not lost as one day a strange
girl shows up who claims she has
selected Sato in a project which will
kill him from his hiki Komori disease
and so Sutter starts his epic road to
recovery as he gets addicted to MMORPGs
joined suicide pacts and makes hentai
games in tag games
yes hence our games the magical place
for tentacle migrate fuck-buddies
breasts Jenny are considered large until
they start January turn your own
gravitational field and every girl's
content on getting a hold of a big gun I
mean what we're really are clothing
anyway this was quite interesting anime
with a very bizarre bunch of characters
the main character Sutter can be
described as one lazy ass [ __ ]
but he's the type of guy who's clever
enough to know that he is bloody lazy
but he's just too lazy to do anything
about it so he's just basically me in
five years except with a shitty haircut
and addiction to smoking and a pedophile
beard he's also really messed up if the
oh and I'm not bleach idiot this is one
sucker you're not gonna suck he's also
really messed up if the talking
furniture weren't a big enough giveaway
but his idiotic outbursts of insanity
make up for the funniest moments in the
series and then we get to Yamazaki
sutter's neighbor and childhood friend
he is one of those annoying types of
geese who never seems to shut up for his
Abhi's couple this is greg heiresses
voice which makes it sound like he's
been smoking 50 packs of cigarettes
every single day and it's not entirely
surprising to find out he was bullied
when he was younger
comer's are gonna stop by a boot that
only has one lousy game don't you
realize that a game is a holistic work
of art if you try overcompensate for
holes in a pot shut up Yamazaki lost two
main characters a Misaki the sweet
little girl trying to save Sato from
Missy kimura disease who's a lot more
messed up than she first appears and his
homie such as old love interest who
planted the whole idea of conspiracies
into his head in the first place this
ban of care does make up a bigger
strength for the show because despite
have really messed up they all are
there's always something about the
problems that they have they can relate
to the darkest times of your own life
making them surprisingly likeable did
dawn dirty [ __ ]
shut up Yamazaki miss lucky just wants
to feel like she's not completely
useless as a person Yamazaki just wants
to achieve something to leave his mark
yeah don't shut up he tummy feels like
the whole world's against her and Sato
is just it's perfect
taking dirty photos of little girls is
exactly what
looky perfect dumbass would do actually
I'm still trying to figure that out as
you can expect from a slice-of-life
anime the series has a lot of comedy
present which plays off with a situation
Sutter gets himself in it's surprisingly
funny to see all the crazy circumstances
such I can get coin to like how he gets
trapped in a pyramid scheme and gets
crazy addicted to online porn though it
does make me wonder how he hasn't
discovered online porn yet considering
he's a twenty-something year old
unemployed guy he does nothing all day
but spend time sitting around alone in
his apartment but whatever be warned
though cuz it is all dark humor which
fits in with the ever depressing and
bleak tone of the series this because
the series goes about tackling the
current social issues in Japan and
there's his comedic Lee buttering the
most entertaining group of depressed
misfits right in the middle and this is
the biggest strength of the series we
all want the characters to succeed in
their goals but we can't help but laugh
when they fell because when they fell
they fell spectacularly making for some
hilarious moments and some quite
depressing moments at times the show
becomes a psychological study all the
characters in the show and you can't
come out this show without feeling a
little bit bleak since a big part of the
show's message is how life is ultimately
meaningless which may not sound like the
greatest message in the world but it's
throw isn't enough comedy to offend the
show from becoming unbearably depressing
and it has the perfect balance of
comedic - desolate moments making this
an entertaining ly depressing show the
animation in the series cuz the usual -
of gonzo treatment meaning about 3/4 of
the series gets done by top-notch
animation directors which results from
really good animation and then the rest
of the episodes presumably get started
some four-year-olds with coloring
pencils the soundtrack also deserves a
special mention since I really did take
a liking to it in the show it consists
of a mixture of insert songs which never
did fail to enhance in motions of the
scenes especially the ones with the
feeling of loneliness and isolation that
are so ever-present in the show except
for one song of course which is so
annoyingly addictive that I will haunt
you in your dreams and if you see in
this show you will know which one I'm
talking about
overall this show was surprisingly good
considering it's not a type of show
would usually watch the characters
likeable and I was some absolutely
hilarious moments in this and even
though you the show is quite depressing
at times I think most people could enjoy
it if they're in a mood for something a
bit darker so this show gets a good
recommendation unless you think your
life is already perfect with all
sunshine and rainbows in which case I
would suggest you go to nearest hardware
store buy a toilet plunger and pull your
head out of your own arse I give this
anime a 9 out of 10 Dad gone dirty
[ __ ]
shut up Yamazaki
ba ba ba ba du Hoc attorney